hey youtubers is Charlie big news Ben
Affleck revealed the title of his Batman
movie is just gonna be called the Batman
as in the one true Batman
which is huge so let's break this down
the title itself feels perfect it's very
simple simple is always better the
Batman it has gravitas it gives it this
classic feel
there was an animated series called the
Batman that ran from 2004 to 2008 but
we've already seen Batman vs Superman so
we have a pretty good idea for what Ben
Affleck's Batman is like although they
have talked a lot about how his arc
works and justice Lee he doesn't kill
people anymore he's becoming more like
the Batman that you're used to reading
about in the comics is if this whole
experience that he's had up to this
point in like the new DC Cinematic
Universe has caused him to question and
re-examine his values so I think this is
probably going to be one of the best
Batman movies of all time just based on
the pitch you know based on all the
stuff that we know about it it's being
co-written by Geoff Johns and Ben
Affleck and it's being directed by Ben
Affleck so based on the powers that they
have in the experience they have like
Geoff Johns brings all this comic-book
experience that Affleck brings all this
classic Hollywood experience they just
have a lot more control over the
expression of the character the film the
narrative so while people like
Christopher Nolan are amazing filmmakers
like one of the best filmmakers today I
feel like in the pantheon of great DC
Comics films there have been a lot of
great DC Comics films most of them
Batman films this version of Batman will
be in that top five but it will be the
best comic book Batman film now the big
difference I think with Christopher
Nolan is is that they were meant to be a
more real world take on the Batman
character so they're amazing Batman
movies but as a comic book movie like
The Dark Knight Rises for instance you
know great movie but not really a Batman
story like Batman wouldn't give up being
Batman at the end he's always going to
be that character so I do have some
issues with the way they ended that
movie like he definitely goes out in a
blaze of glory but you always want the
end of the Batman movie to feel like
he's charging forward into his next
adventure even though at the end of Dark
Knight even if he didn't like that
and you're like well yeah of course
something is gonna bring Batman back
even if that version of Robin became
Batman which was kind of what
Christopher Nolan was teasing like he
was gonna pick up the mantle of the bat
Bruce Wayne would eventually have to
come back they've done that a couple
times in the comics I feel like their
big crisis events it's been a little
while but they're been at least two or
three times when Batman has just either
died outright or people thought that he
was dead so they had battle for the cowl
so like all the Robins and other people
vie for the mantle of the bat until
Bruce Wayne comes back but that's the
idea he always comes back so even though
there'll be some day when Ben Affleck
will eventually stop playing Batman you
don't want them to end it with him dying
in Batman going away in the movie
universe you want somebody else to pick
up the cowl somebody else will be Batman
and hopefully they'll have some fun with
the idea of the recast day but this is
like so far off we're talking like 15 20
you know who knows how long like Robert
Downey jr. is gonna be Iron Man for a
long time he'll just age into the role
of old Tony Stark the funny thing about
the title and it's an awesome title is
you wonder what's the next movie gonna
be called will it be the Batman and dot
dot dot or the Batman versus dot dot dot
because the number naming scheme of
movies like calling it the Batman to the
Batman 3 has gone out the window that
went out a long time ago movie studios
found that people got really fatigued
when you started numbering movies so
when you say stuff like Star Trek 6
they'll always be a core audience that
will always go see a franchise just
because they love those characters but
general movie audiences are just in
general get less excited about numbered
sequels than they do about movies that
are called say like Batman V Superman or
Avengers infinity war which is why like
Marvel for instance they have like a
two-part infinity war movie just decided
to go a different route and call the
first part of that infinity war and
they'll call the second infinity war
movie something completely different
like they'll completely differentiate
those movies so like Man of Steel
they're making a Man of Steel sequel but
it's not going to be called Man of Steel
2 that's just kind of like a working
title right now so let me know what do
you think the next Batman movie after
this coming one after the Batman will be
called will they continue with the the
title I think they'll probably try to
stick with that and they won't do the
Dark Knight again just because that's a
Christopher Nolan thing like they always
try to do something a little bit
different they've never done the Batman
before so it's an awesome name and it
sounds kind of new and familiar at the
same time which is like the sweet spot
that movie studios try to hit they
wanted to feel familiar but not the
exact same thing that you heard a couple
years ago with Christopher Nolan but the
really smart change they made behind the
scenes is that they decided they're just
not gonna rush these films anymore so if
it takes a little bit longer to make a
little bit longer to figure the script
out to get things in order before they
make big announcements they'll just take
that time which i think is a smart move
like there was a quote from James Gunn a
while ago where he said he felt like the
reason why there were a lot of bad big
blockbuster movies being released is
because Studios were making them based
on a specific release schedule before
they actually had those movies in hand
so like you say okay we're gonna release
10 movies each on this date each year
for the next 10 years but you have
absolutely no idea what those movies are
gonna be it's just a recipe for disaster
it's always better to know exactly what
the films gonna be to have a script
before you put it on your schedule so
they've been working on the Batman for a
while now Ben Affleck probably still
riding the script with Geoff Johns it's
probably not done yet but they've been
working on it for a long time so they
have a pretty good idea of what the
movies gonna be they don't have an
official release date yet the CEO of
Time Warner said 18 months but I think
they just want to get it out within at
least two years of Justice League coming
out which is at the end of next year
which would mean like end of 2019 at the
latest I think they try to make it a
spring movie if they could or at least
early summer they've already announced
Deathstroke is going to be the villain
in Ben Affleck actually just did an
interview where he talked a little bit
about why he chose Deathstroke
specifically and he just said he's a
great villain because I just had this
instinctive feeling that he would match
up with Batman really well you know I'm
a big admirer of that character is well
he's talking about Deathstroke
especially in the new 52 the way they
did Deathstroke
and I thought that that could work
so really like the only thing that stood
out for me like I totally agree with
what he said Deathstroke is a great
character he'd be great villain for
pretty much any DC character but the
only double-take I had was when he said
new 52 just because you know most
comic-book people I feel like people
that don't read comics don't really care
the like okay well you know whatever it
just came from a certain era in the
comics but if you're big comic book
reader you're like hey wait a minute
didn't they just throw the new 52 in the
garbage we'll all say to that is is it
the like there were things in the new 52
that weren't so terrible the new 52 is a
concept wasn't so great and some of the
things the directions they took some of
the heroes wasn't so great but I feel
like the villains didn't suffer quite so
much it was really the heroes that
suffer during the new 52 in terms of
character development but let me know in
the comments what other villains do you
feel like would be great matches for
Batman that they have not done in movies
before like they haven't done Clayface
they have Killer Croc now they haven't
done a Batman vs Killer Croc movie yet
so I feel like there are a lot of Batman
rows that they haven't sucked like they
haven't done hush they haven't done
court of owls in the movies yet there
are just so many different stories that
they could do and I feel like that's
what they're trying to do stuff that you
have not seen before so like we've seen
the Riddler we've seen Batman vs. the
Joker and even though there will always
be some Joker in Batman movies I feel
like he won't be the ultimate end goal
like they'll always try to do something
a little bit different with the
characters so just because they're doing
different villains doesn't mean they're
not also going to do some of the classic
ones too but get hype in the flash and
arrow or back this week this is a big DC
week now there's a lot of Marvel TV -
hopefully you've seen mostly Luke Cage
Ghost Rider is still going strong
so what's gonna happen is is I'll be
posting my flash video tomorrow after
the episode airs same thing for arrow
agents of shield will probably post
Wednesday morning so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff it's
gonna be awesome well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for that
Deathstroke teaser again and you can
click here for my winter channel update
for like all the stuff that's happening
to the next couple of months thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight